ça ça s'appelle le glacier donc dans les
années 30 voilà comment
on racontait en images le glacier aux
élèves
en primaire c'était en primaire
aujourd'hui vous reprenez une image de
glacier c'est pas du tout comme ça
[Musique]
l'ascension vers le Mont Blanc en
1865 c'était plutôt aluminées donc elles
ont elles ont vieilli jaunies mais elle
montre bien ce qui était la montagne à
cette époque là
[Musique]
c'est ça que vous avez pu
là vu ce qu'on voit maintenant
malheureusement il y aura plus grand
chose à photographier ici d'ici deux
trois ans de trois ans quatre ans je
sais pas mais ça feront à une telle
vitesse et c'est dingue elle a chaud
elle craque elle parle le elle crie elle
c'est
elle a mal la montagne a mal
malheureusement
elle a pas besoin d'un bon coup de froid
et d'un bon coup de frais pour aller
mieux une petite cryothérapie ça lui
ferait du bien
[Musique]